let's give Diana a stab at this Diana
how you doing hi I'm good what do you
got for me tonight
what's up my question
um kind of like how do we as women who
maybe are I I don't want to say like
like super big boss babes but like just
confident in who we are as a person
confident in our careers Our Lives as
they are how do we tone it down
without changing who we are as a person
yeah that's tough isn't it because
what do you do for a living
so I am a physical therapist by trade
but I do I'm a PPS coordinator right now
so I do coding and chart reviews and all
that stuff for a hospital to make sure
we don't get audited okay yeah so how do
you turn that off is what the question
is
how do I why how do you turn that off is
what you're asking me well my question
was like just in dating right I have
been labeled as aggressively sarcastic
because that's my personality but I do
have friends and myself like I have a
doctor a physical therapy degree not
that I'm going airing out that stuff to
people like on a first date or anything
like that but I just find that maybe
sometimes
um yeah that is intimidating but I don't
want to like not be who I am as a person
just because somebody else feels
intimidated by that that to me seems
like maybe their confidence level is not
where it needs to be
um but you know watching the clip that
you showed of that date which was a very
awkward scenario all the way around how
often do you see that in your own
personal life when you did
uh I see it often like the softer guys
are difficult they're awkward socially
anxious they're not calibrated to the
conversation you see that a lot I see
it's I would say 50 50 is how often I
see it
um just because
I like watching that was hard to watch I
don't rattle off questions left and
right like that I like to be asked a
question and marinate it marinate on it
for a little bit firing off questions I
mean you might as well just like here's
my resume at that point kind of
situation
um but there are definitely times and I
don't know if it's just because people
are nervous that the the conversation is
awkward which is totally fine I give
people the benefit of the doubt
um but
in those situations it's difficult as a
female to be labeled that way
um and so yeah I'm just wondering what
is the easiest way or how
um
could we be perceived better I don't and
again I don't know if it's it might just
be all chalk it up to personality at
that point
yeah your personality is pretty much
hardwired by the time you're in your 20s
and 30s isn't it
how old are you 33.
and what's your plan are you like you
dating you're looking for uh a guide
boyfriend family like what's the
strategy for you yeah I mean I'm single
I'm looking I'm not aggressively looking
I'm not that type of female that like is
trying like we watched I feel like
that's another thing there's women out
there out of desperation because oh
we're in our 30s oh oh it was me all my
kids are all my friends have kids and
that's just not how I am I want my life
to turn out the way it's supposed to
um so yeah I'm you know dating like out
there looking to date but I'm not trying
to get married tomorrow either so but I
mean like you understand there's a
timeline though and
you know like you have to sort of get
things moving if you want to have a
family right like it's not something you
can put off for too late no it's not but
at the end of the day I realize that
either it's in the cards for me or it's
not I'm not gonna Force something I'm
not gonna Force somebody to be with me
or settle because I want a family and
I'm on a timeline yeah
um
so I mean the guys in the chat sort of
talk amongst themselves that's that's
how chat seems to work but uh you're
throwing off like strong boss girl Vibes
right it's like I got this you know I'm
good either way I do well in life you
know everything's good you've taken care
of yourself you're obviously an
attractive woman you can date you don't
have a problem with that but what you're
going to start running into is I mean
you're starting to see it right now is
that about half the guys you're dealing
with they're not very masculine right
they don't know how to calibrate to
a girl to begin with let alone a strong
girl because that's what you are right
have you always lived by yourself
yes
for how long
um I've lived by myself for about four
years now I lived with a boyfriend the
last time I was living with someone okay
why did that end
um that ended because we just didn't see
life the same way
um he was in the military which happy
Memorial Day and to all those serving
and all that I have absolutely no
problem with the military because I
don't want that to come off as like
something but he you know as far as like
back then when I wanted to get married
to him and have kids he wanted to pursue
his career which is fine but I can't be
you know I couldn't have I wasn't able
to be strung along like that
um so that's just kind of how it ended
so you ended it it was a mutual thing
yeah and I feel like you know I was in
my early to mid 20s we were both
changing as people and I just kind of
feel like we decided that we really were
not meant to be together how long ago
was that
uh four years ago yeah so you've been
dating for four years you haven't found
a guy that was worthy for for anything
longer term no I my last relationship I
was in was two years ago
um and why did that one end that one
ended
um because we fought a lot and I don't
think that it was a very healthy
relationship
um
he was the type of person that did not
make me a priority and that's what what
led to so many fights not making you a
priority like can you give me an example
yeah so he was in television
um so he was very much about his image
and all of that and
friends were above all everybody else
was above all his you know himself he
was above all which is fine I'm not
saying I don't ever want to be someone's
number one priority I should never be in
someone's number one priority but I
always felt like I was at the bottom of
the totem pole just I almost felt like I
was begging for his attention
um and so that's pretty much why it
ended I mean a woman wants a guy with a
sparkle in his eye but they don't want
that sparkle to be them right
yeah so so
this is where things get a little touchy
difficult right so you're with the top
shelf guy he's in television he's making
his career his his priority
um
what's wrong with that exactly like
what's wrong with him putting that dent
in the universe and then you know taking
you along for the ride and you're a
passenger on that bus and you build a
family together
there was nothing wrong with that part
of it but it's when you're putting it
was other people so for instance he had
a lot of friends who were girls which I
don't have a problem with but at the
same time if they're people that I
haven't met that you use to date and
you're going out to dinner with them but
you haven't taken me out to dinner in a
while then what are we doing here
you know it's just like it was there's
even some doors open is what you think
yeah okay
okay yeah well look I mean
if if you've got the intention to go in
a certain direction find a guy have a
family settle down do all that stuff
that's fine you know that's why we're
here right that's why we're on the
planet to do all these things
you're gonna have to date
categorically with intention in that
area but without coming off as to terse
if you know what I mean do you know what
the word terse means no but I guess I
could look it up yeah so it's a funny
story so I used to work in collections
back in my 20s and I had a I had a
review you know you go in every year and
they they you know review you write all
this [__] down and you'd read and I was
like what the hell is terse mean right
and it's like it's one of the words that
sort of stuck out because that's who I
am right like I'm a firstborn I want to
get [__] done I don't sugarcoat things
rainbows and butterflies aren't for me
but I'm a man and that works right you
you do come off as a little bit terse
right like you do come off as a little
bit harsh you do come off you know I was
like I got this I don't need a man you
know like I I can figure this out and
you know what even if it doesn't get
figured out I'll still be okay
but but the truth of the matter is is
there's loads and loads of women in
their 40s and 50s that never have the
opportunity to have a family that don't
have any kids that are surrounding
themselves with pets you know a lot of
the times they're trying to you know
placate that vacuum you know with
something
um
soften it down a little bit right
um there's um
there's a lady on YouTube Suzanne wanker
and she talks more to women when it
comes down to you know getting to the
point of you know
building a family Dynamic and having
children all that sort of stuff she's
got a lot of really good podcasts you
know in that area and she tries to help
women out I think women will more than
likely listen to something like that but
I can tell you from from the perspective
of the kind of guy that you want I know
the exact type of like Avatar that
you're looking for
um you're you're not going to be the
priority at the end of the day but you
will be important and what he's looking
for is he's looking for a woman that
will be a compliment to his life not the
focus of it you see what I'm saying yeah
like uh and you have to be okay with
that right like you have to be okay with
coming in that place because your place
in that and that guy's life is going to
end up being the mother you know the
Homemaker
you're not gonna be the breadwinner
right because you because you want to
date that guy that's better than you you
know you want that that iron candy that
you can show up you know with your
friends been bring them out to
Thanksgiving hey this is Bob you know
Big Bob sort of over here right yeah
everybody's got like a nickname for him
but
yeah you got to soften down a little bit
you know what I mean like you gotta you
know you gotta stop drinking the uh the
boss [__] Kool-Aid you know
drink some water you know from time to
time and and stop sipping you know
sipping on the hardcore stuff because
when you come off that edgy you gotta
remember like when guys are out working
hard and they're putting a dent in the
universe and they're and they're doing
something of some significance they
don't want to come home to a nightmare
they don't want to come home to a fight
they don't want to come home to why
you know it's like you know they want
pleasantries they want love they want a
nice meal they want to be kissed you
know they want to see beauty yeah you
know I mean and I will say like in a
relationship I'm not edgy like this I
love a healthy banter but I always like
turn myself as like the Sour Patch Kid
first what do you think that I'm sweet
sort of situation what do you think
would happen if I if if we called your
ex right now and asked him is Diana
a bit tough is she a little bit terse
I think he would agree with you in a
sense
um but at the same time my ex was a nice
guy so I wasn't always as I was
definitely toned down for that because I
can read a room I can I understand that
um but I will say that you know part of
my terseness if you want to call it that
definitely has a lot to do with just the
society we live in these days I mean as
you said you know
um guys are being made to be weaker and
I and you like you said women are being
made to be stronger it's not that that's
how I necessarily have made myself into
it but I feel like the society we live
in and I will say a lot of the guys that
I have gone on dates with the ones that
are like just down to you know have sex
and all that kind of stuff I'm not going
to be nice to that person I don't want
to be nice to that person that's
disrespectful towards me so I feel like
a lot of that terseness is initial
because I'm trying to you know it's an
effective mechanism yeah so how do you
balance out protecting yourself
from guys like that and also still being
feminine to attract the right guy right
like the soft side of the feminine gal
that you need to be like the number one
selling book in the world is um
uh it's something about
um [__] uh men love [__] or
something like that you know the book
that I'm talking about right yeah what's
it called I can't remember but I it's
something like that but I don't remember
exactly what it's called I've never read
it have any of your girlfriends read it
or talked about it why men love why why
men love [__] thank you muff yeah
that one yeah this is this is the number
one selling book in the world when it
comes to giving advice on love and
dating in the landscape and it's like it
is the worst book I've ever gone through
and it essentially masculinized women
tells them to be disagreeable basically
tells them to be boss [__] right it's
like guys don't want to deal with that
they want a Woman They wanna you know
they want somebody soft and beautiful
and feminine with curves it smells nice
you know they don't want you know the
hen pecking stuff before we wrap up let
me ask you a question your your ideal
guy what age range would he be in
um probably anywhere from 30 to like 45.
okay so I'm just gonna pull up my uh
calculator here exclude married
obviously because you don't want to date
a married guy uh Jimny preference for uh
race white black Asian or any color
shade matter for you
um not necessarily no okay minimum
height for you do you have a height
preference for guys
um probably like
5 10 and above I guess okay how tall are
you
five three five ten is pretty pretty
good like is that a is that a hard line
in sand you won't do like a five eight
well if I if I'm in
six inch heels and I'm I mean I I'm just
basing it off my heel height so if I'm
in six inch heels and I'm at least the
same height around so okay five nine you
want to go five nine that's fine okay so
let's drag the bar down to five nine and
exclude obese you like fit guys or does
that even matter I'm down for a dad Bond
oh that Bots not obese
okay so we'll so we'll just exclude that
then uh minimum income how much money
they have to make to Vegas I'm not like
money is not uh matter like it does not
matter to me at least what you do that's
all that matters to me at least what you
make I would imagine
that's fine I've dated guys who have not
made as much as me okay
so
there's this online calculator that was
created by some engineers and some geeks
on
ideal men and women's dating preferences
uh it's the URL is I got
standardsbro.com so it's kind of a funny
uh one here but let me let me share it
with you on the screen just to sort of
give you an idea of what your
demographics look like not married any
race at least five foot nine not obese I
put earning at least 85 000 a year in
that age range in the demographics in
North America the chance of you finding
that guy is about 1.7 percent of the
male population it's pretty low now you
know when you factor in
that guys don't really want to deal with
difficulties top shelf guys you know
kind of like the kind of guys that
you're gonna want to Chase and I'm not
saying Chase men but the kind of guys
that you want you know to invite into
your life to create a family with
they've got a lot of options
they've got a lot of options so being
Pleasant being agreeable like these are
all things that you're that you're gonna
have to kind of come to grips with or
don't you know you can just kind of
carry on just be like I'm I'm just gonna
do me
I'm just going to do me but what I can
tell you from experience and I've talked
to lots and lots of dudes now thousands
you know at this point and I've gotten
lots and lots of feedback been doing
these podcasts for years now is most
guys don't want to deal with the
difficulties of headaches when it comes
to getting pushed around run in a
relationship if if they're going to lead
because women want guys to lead they
want to look up to a giant they want to
be in a guy's frame you know they don't
want to be with a wimp yeah if there's
if there's one thing I know that discuss
women is wimpy men
right so you've got to soften your tone
you've got to soften your demeanor you
got to tune into your feminine side
okay
good luck Diana thank you I appreciate
it all right take care I really hope you
guys enjoyed that clip if you want to
watch the full length podcast you can
find that over here that clips from if
you're new to the channel make sure you
hit subscribe over here and pin down
below in the top comment you'll find a
bunch of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out